So world-class entrepreneurs are never lucky. Never.
You make your own luck. It’s a big idea you know At a
single point in time, you’ll say, yeah, just happened to be
there when X happened there. Geez, that’s just kind of
happened and I was there when somebody said X or Y
over a career. You will now look back and go you were not
lucky. You showed up more than other people. You took
advantage of more other people you raised your hand
more often, you were there more often you got on a plane
where everybody else went ‘ah, it’s too much of a hassle.
World-class entrepreneurs do that over time consistently.
And you could tell the difference of whether you’re gonna
make it or not is when everybody else says ‘nah, too much
worker ‘what do you mean I got to drive over there’ or ‘you
mean I have to talk to those guys it’s just too much about’
or nah that is just too hard.’ I want you to remember that.
That adds up over time in a career and you will start making
your own luck and you will find because stuff will start
coming your way. Does this make sense, right? Yes, this
conference happened to happen but you guys decided to
go to it. Somebody who I gave you a little hint that perhaps
you needed to do that. But my point is don’t – right
don’t ever think what happens to other people and
I want you guys to understand the distinction between
standing there waiting for direction versus making your
own direction by making it happen. So just as an side
keep going, guys, this is good. Well, we
thought these guys would know this big problem so it's
existed. It’s a big shift, right, where you think they are just
going to grab it out with your hands and now you realized,
geez, there is a portion of evangelism here and just
to remember, if you’re right and new market turns into an
existing market fairly rapidly, right? Yeah, yeah. But at least
on day one, when you’re ahead of the game with the things
you need to do about evangelism about scale, about
wether you are selling or evangelizing is really kind of
different. pitching team other comments or..? That’s alright -
quickly it that getting the people you’re talking to as
your customers to be talking about this problem itself is part
of your journey now as he explained. Getting that message
out there and making your company solution part of the
conversation at all the conferences six months and a year
from now, is like a critical thing to do, because if you do it
your portfolio’s looking better then. ..that...
So the point is this that a lot of – the reason
of pushing on these points that we’re
talking about these things is a lot of the pivots are
off understanding the complexity of that chart, more
the pivots are off there are some complexity the markets
not penetrable understanding the ecosystem, there’s no
insertion point for a new technology or new company.
Those are probably more of the reasons for the pivot
stand around the core technology. So the sooner
you understand that ecosystem, the sooner you’ll
have a sense of where you want to stay with it. And just
you know, hope to see that in you guys, you may look at the
fuel cell market structure and go ‘it’s just not penetrable
for a new entrant even though the technology is applicable.
Right. So what are you doing for tomorrow? For tomorrow,
we’re going to go try and visit the planning board for
Redwood City and see what they’re thinking about
is that - they’re working on this cost per vote the salmation
plant trying to talk with them about how they are
thinking about that project. And some of you are
probably wishing that now but I have to tell you how
proud I am of each and everyone of you here because
you’re going to look back and what you did here, most
of you, and go ‘holy cow did we actually do that in a class
or we were taking a course and doing work and everything
else? and so for me, it’s just a really impressive effort on
all your parts. Any other comments? Yeah, I’m guessing
for some of you this was the hardest class you might
have taken. And that’s the intent because as hard as
this class might have been, it’s so much easier then when
you get out and do it for real. So the laboratory was a sort
of safe place to stretch your muscles and see if it fits.
And for a lot of you, I think it does and I’m thrilled to have
been a part of it, I think you guys have done a great job
yeah. Thank you, guys, congratulations and best of luck
to all you on Monday. Next Monday you start it for yourself
for real.So final comment. I would just share is that
by design this class is not taught, right. It’s experienced We
set up a framework under Steve’s leadership that gets
you out of the classroom and then we all sort of monitor each other